I want to make a little
clarification for the last
three videos.
They've all been of the form:
determine whether the
statement is always, sometimes,
or never true, and
explain why.
And then this was the actual
statement that they gave in
the last problem.
And to be frank, I think these
problems are written-- They're
not completely well
constructed.
Because when they say the
statement, the assumption is,
that this whole thing over
here is this statement.
That this whole thing
is a statement.
Not just this first part.
Not just the 3x is greater
than or equal to x.
So if you assume that this whole
thing is a statement, we
saw in the last video that
this is never true.
I mean 3x is greater than or
equal to x only if x is
greater than or equal to 0.
We saw this in the last video.
It is not true for
all real numbers.
3x is greater than or equal
to x is not true
for all real numbers.
This is not true for
all real numbers.
And the reason why I say that
this was kind of a strangely
constructed question is I think
the goal of the problem
writer is that they wanted
us to write sometimes.
Which is what we did
in the last videos.
But if you say sometimes, you're
actually interpreting
this as the statement,
not the whole thing.
You could say that 3x is greater
than or equal to x
sometimes for certain
real numbers.
Sometimes.
This is true.
You can say this is
true sometimes.
But this whole thing, 3x is
greater than or equal to x for
all or numbers, is not
sometimes true and
sometimes not true.
This is never true.
You can never say it's
for all real numbers.
It's not like this is true on
Monday and then on Tuesday
this becomes not true.
And then on Wednesday
it becomes true.
This is never true.
Because the statement for all
real numbers just won't work.
You can't say for all real
numbers 3x is greater than or
equal to x.
I hope I'm not muddying
up the issue here.
But I want to make
it very clear.
Because the statement is
a false statement.
This is a false statement.
So if you really want to think
about it, if you view this
whole thing as a statement, this
statement is never true.
It's not like it's true on
Monday and then all of a
sudden not true the next month
after that or all of a sudden
it becomes true again.
No, it's never going
to be true.
I don't care how long you wait
or how far in the past you go,
this statement will never be
true that 3x is greater than
or equal to x for all
real numbers x.
The problem writer wanted us to
circle sometimes because as
I already stated-- and I'm
maybe getting a little
repetitive here --because I
think they wanted us to think
about the statement as 3x is
greater than or equal to x.
So my general opinion-- I mean,
3x is greater than or
equal to x sometimes for
some real numbers.
But not for all real numbers.
So you'd say sometimes if
this was the statement.
And you would say never
true if this whole
thing was the statement.
I hope I'm not muddying up.
But it's always important
because I think sometimes some
of the hardest questions in
algebra are, to some degree,
strangely constructed questions
where the answer
writer was, or the question
writer was, trying to get you
to go in some direction.
And I actually looked at what
they wanted and that's why I
wrote and said sometimes.
But, if you really think about
it, the answer is never.